rock en seine plus de cent dix mille
visiteurs sur trois jours venus braver
un dernier week-end d'août caniculaire
dans le parc du domaine de saint cloud
un rendez-vous qui depuis presque quinze
ans permettent au détour des allées de
constater l'engouement des franciliens
pour les cours de danse avec une dizaine
de leçons programme encadrés par des
professionnels
les vinyles également à l'honneur avec
le désormais traditionnel village des
disquaires mercun scène c'est surtout
des moments d'anthologie avec cette
année le presque septuagénaire iggy pop
en tête d'affiche pour 2016 le festival
s'est une nouvelle fois ouvert aux
autres genres musicaux notamment le rap
et casseurs flotteurs sont venus et
achevé leur tournée estivale
dernier coup d'éclat après un film et
une série télé regarde regarde regarde
le poteau comme à côté il a une tronche
de rappeurs et nous on est dans un show
nerveux qui ce que je pense qu'ils
s'équipent qu'il ya des connivences avec
le l'énergie rock on amorce une
transition là c'est la dernière datar
concernent des casseurs
les trois ans qu'on bosse le projet
casseurs et là on sent qu'on a on allait
tirer le projet dans tous les sens et
qu'on on pourrait risquer dessous les
gens si on continue et puis ce sens mais
rld et nous les premiers
et derrière on a plein de projets solos
les uns les autres claude par son
premier album l'album effet il n'ya plus
qu'à le masterisé maintenant on va
commencer à envoyer un clip à la rentrée
merci en marge des artistes confirmés
des talents en devenir rock en seine en
festivals pour promouvoir musiciens et
chanteurs franciliens débutants la
région principal partenaire ainsi sa
propre scène chaque année ils étaient
une douzaine à s'y produire pour cette
édition tim de m
à 21 ans il est originaire de
rambouillet fait j'ai rencontré mes
managers qui sont un directeur de le mba
sa noire dans le 95 dans le val d'oise
et on fait battre c'est notamment avec
eux que j'ai eu
j'ai pu avoir un programme
d'accompagnement notamment avec arcady
qui fonctionne aussi avec la région ile
de france
en tout cas pour moi
d'être trop gras mais là sur la scène
d'ile-de-france et nouvelle étape et
changeons par guy d'autant que tu
traverses quand tu prends tu es
parmi les autres artistes issus de
l'ile-de-france qui hoyaux et son
mélange de soul de blues et de rock des
années 70 qui l'ad'abord rôder dans les
couloirs du métro lui aussi a bénéficié
d'une aide de la région qui lui a permis
de réaliser des premières parties
d'artistes majeurs
mais pour réussir il s'est également
pris en main en allant se produire aux
états unis ouais ça m'a donné une force
aussi de nous de voir que jouer là-bas
pouvoir rencontrer des gens et de
l'échangé avec eux et écoliers ce
feeling qui passe quoi tu vois ça m'a
permis de me dire que je pouvais revenir
ici
chez clients b
au total l'île de france compterait plus
de 20000 groupes de musiques actuelles
la région on tombe bien valorisé de
cette richesse et toutes nos stratégies
culturelles qu'on va dévoiler en
septembre elle est fondée sur l'idée
d'inclusion inclusion c'est quoi ça veut
dire que dans un quartier populaire dans
une zone rurale au fin-fond l'île de
france
eh bien on peut devenir soi-même acteurs
culturels et on peut aussi avoir accès à
la culture
et l'an prochain la région sera une
nouvelle fois présente sur le festival
rock en seine aux groupes régionaux de
se montrer à la hauteur et de ne pas
hésiter le développent